good day and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please
allow me to welcome you to this edition
of our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture is supported by the uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and by a
grant from the national institutes of
general
medical sciences it's my honor and
privilege to welcome our speaker today
dr jessica turner
associate professor of psychology from
georgia state university
she completed her bachelor of arts
degree in psychology and mathematics
from swarthmore college
a master's of arts in social sciences
from the university of california irvine
in 1992 and in 1997 completed her phd in
psychology
from the university of california irvine
she has been
an assistant professor in residence at
the cal irvine
and from 2010 to 2013 an assistant
professor at the university of new
mexico where she was part of the
translational neuroscience
mind research network in albuquerque new
mexico uh
since um uh about presently
she has been an associate professor in
the department of psychology at georgia
state
university in atlanta and under the
direction of professor turner her lab
investigates the genetics underlying
brain structural changes
in chronic schizophrenia as well as the
genetic influences
on functional and structural neural
imaging measurements in
many other neuropsychological disorders
and diseases
she has a particular focus on the
development of formal computable
representations of neuroimaging
experiments
the experimental variables involved in
the results of data from automated data
sharing
and meta-analyses within neurobiology
all of her work is conducted in close
collaboration with psychiatrists
computer scientists
geneticists and neuroscientists in
research on the genetics of brain
function and dysfunction she has
been a key participant and contributor
to several large-scale nih-funded
programs in brain research notably the
biomedical informatics research network
coordinating center uh the skids connect
project as well as many others
and her lecture today is entitled enigma
and coin stack
turning small data sets into big ones as
always we are streaming this lecture
live
and for recording via youtube if you are
watching on youtube thank you so
much for joining us also our specially
selected uh 2020 2021 biomedical data
science innovation lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr turner via the chat feature in
their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and
ask them on your behalf during about the
last 10 minutes or so
of dr turner's lecture and with that
welcome
jess thank you so much we are really
looking forward to your lecture
thank you hopefully everybody can hear
me and
here we are um move on through it
thank you so much for inviting me to
give this presentation today i want to
talk about
um really a culmination
or the current stage of a long progress
of creating big data sets from
smaller ones there's been a long history
in neuroimaging of which
dr van horn has been was a key player in
helping
neuro imaging researchers to share their
data to take data sets from
individual studies um so that they could
be
combined considered compared in ways
that you can't if you just look at the
literature
so today i wanted to talk about two
efforts that have been
um ongoing in this progress over the
last uh
decade um one of which is the enigma
effort and its working groups which is a
largely
human dependent approach to
large-scale data sharing and analysis
and one of which
is coinstec which is a more automated
approach and these two groups have
actually gotten together which is why i
have an enigma coinstack
uh presentation to talk to you about so
for those of you who don't know enigma
for those of you who do i'm going to
apologize about half the talks about
enigma and its history enigma stands for
enhancing neuroimaging genetics through
meta-analysis it was really started in
2009 it was
largely the brainchild of dr paul
thompson
now at usc and at that time
um hard to believe as it was but if you
cast your mind back into the early 2000s
those of us who are trying to put
together brain measurements neuroimaging
and genetics um really had a hope that
if we could get to 200
500 maybe a thousand subjects um
that we would be able to identify
genetic effects on brain measurements
more very robustly um and it
and it was becoming very clear that that
wasn't the case that we were going to
take um
thousands of subjects in which is larger
than any one person
can collect and uh paul's real stroke of
genius
was to recognize that we could actually
um leave the data where it is um so
everybody
had data sets of 100 people 200 people
which we thought were astoundingly large
for narrow imaging
but they weren't large enough uh and the
idea would be
could we actually just interact with
everybody who has those data
who has genetic data genome-wide scan
data and
uh brain imaging data and have everybody
do the same analysis so voluntarily
agree to do the same analysis on their
own data
and then aggregate those results for a
meta-analysis
and that way we don't have to jump
through all the hoops of data sharing we
don't have to jump through all the hoops
of
moving the data so that you have 10 000
data sets in one
university's um resources
but we just send summary results back
and forth and there's
a huge lowering of the bar
when people when you say oh i don't have
to give you my data
i just have to do some analysis and we
can actually
um we can actually put it together and
do a meta-analysis
but it's not the same as a literature
meta-analysis
because it is a prospective what we call
perspective meta-analysis because
everybody
does the same analysis as opposed to
reading the literature and doing
everybody
you know perhaps have done having done
their own idiosyncratic analysis
and and published it so it avoids the
heterogeneity of an analysis
of heterogeneity of analysis that you
get from a sort of standard
a literature driven meta-analysis and it
also avoids to some extent the um
the file drawer problem where
data that's too small that doesn't find
a significant result
doesn't get published and you never know
about it
so in this case we're really asking
people to reach into their file drawer
and reuse their own data um and it
turned out
that he got a huge response he literally
just emailed you know friends and
friends and family and uh shipped it
around his his imaging
networks and imaging genetics networks
and had a positive response from quite a
few
uh people so in 2012 these were the the
groups from around the country who were
participating in the first
analyses by 2014 it had grown
tremendously
and more recently it's now at
43 countries researchers across 43
countries it's organically organized
into
51 working groups and 31
around 31 different disorders and it's
just
really taken off so from its original
analyses which were literally genomic
association studies of
subcortical methods so they had a group
working on how do we actually
standardize the subcortical protocol so
that everybody can do it
how do we do the genetics in such a way
that we can do the meta-analysis
appropriately afterwards that was sort
of the first the first start
since then there have been many many
groups working
on different interactions of genetics
and
imaging different aspects of genetics
epigenetics etc how do we actually deal
with that how do we collaborate with
other imaging genetics groups that maybe
are not part of
of enigma but are doing their own thing
within the imaging there have been a
huge number of
imaging protocols suitable for
multi-site meta-analysis and
mega-analysis that have been
uh developed the initial analyses sort
of ignored disorder
even though many of the studies which
were participating
in the meta-analysis had collected their
data because they were interested in
schizophrenia or bipolar disorder
attention deficit
once the first papers came out the again
a sort of self-organization
occurred whereby working groups um who
were
part of the original analysis but now
wanted to focus on schizophrenia bipolar
disorder etc
grew up and then those have expanded now
into again over
over 30 different disorders that are
using these same sorts of models
to examine examine neuroimaging in their
disorder as well as other questions that
are perhaps not disease related
maturation over the lifespan changes
over a shorter period of time
lateralization
etc now the reason enigma can be
so successful is it was
in many cases really dependent on
previously existing informatics or easy
informatics to
to implement for those of you who may
not be familiar with neuro imaging
free surfer is a piece of software
that's been around for probably 30 years
that has been used to analyze structural
images to look at gray and white
matter volumes and shape and other kinds
of measures and they have used
the same directory structure since the
early 90s
to store the inputs and outputs of their
data so that was highly standardized
not optimized but highly standardized
and everybody knew how to work with them
so we could easily write scripts that
would work with these directory trees
pull
out the measurements that we really want
which could then be automated using in
our
original cases it was all r scripts that
could run
on anybody's system to do the regression
zip it all up
and ship it back to the central site for
a meta-analysis
so completely dependent on people making
sure that they could run free surfer
run the scripts run the r scripts but
these r scripts could be
uh standardized across everybody's sites
for
um a standard analysis we all would
agree on exactly what regressions we
want to do etc
so in the first paper from 2012
they ended up looking at data from 13
000
subjects this is really the first
success of enigma
in many ways looking at human
hippocampal intracranial volumes and the
entire
genome or genome-wide association study
and identifying regions
in the hippocampus that didn't quite hit
even with 13 000 data points didn't
quite
hit significance um
but uh it did seem to be identifying
areas that were related to genes which
were important in brain development
very nice kind of results and the
important thing um
for me the the reason that i'm such a
fan of the enigma approach is really
shown here in this forest plot
where what you're seeing is every site
that contributed data to the
to the first meta-analysis and the
effect
uh the effect size and a confidence
interval
for that data set for that locus and and
hippocampal volume
and you can see that individually no
site reaches significance none of these
results would ever have been published
in the literature as being
genome-wide association significant in
any way
but the trend is very consi surprisingly
consistent
um across all of the data sets so that
when you look at the consensus results
in a meta-analysis you really see that
there there seems to be an effect there
and the lovely thing about it was not
only do they do one in meta-analysis but
they did
two um using a similar number of
subjects and the the meta the
replication showed exactly
the same sort of result leading to a
very exciting
finding and then of course they could
replicate that and extend it the next
paper in 2015 that looked at all of the
subcortical brain structures
included data from 30 30 000
participants around the world
and uh excitedly it sort of turned out
that the the hippocampus is not where we
should have been looking the putamen is
really where
the strong genetic effects um just
outstandingly strong genetic effects
were found when you had the power to
really aggregate this data and these
results
and look at it across 30 000 subjects
and of course more recently now up to 50
000 subjects and they're able to do the
same analysis
across the entire cerebral cortex
looking at
all of the brain regions there and
identifying
genome-wide significant effects on
cortical gray matter thickness and other
measurements
so of course these this approach is
imminently scalable you've i've already
shown
that we've been broken up into uh
working groups
shall we say loosely organized into
working groups because many people
of course have multiple trans diagnostic
interests and participate in multiple of
these
research groups but each one of the
groups has
looked at case control differences using
these approaches
aggregating results from around the
world to identify where do we see case
control effects across the cortex and
the subcortex
and how and now we can say how does that
actually relate
across the different disorders so that
we have major depression bipolar
disorder
theo van erp and i run the schizophrenia
working group
and you can see of course that you can
compare very nicely the cortical
pattern of results across these
different disorders and each of these
papers and analyses really pulls from
thousands of
cases and controls around the world
really helping to nail down
these effects and effect sizes um in
these
in these disorders of course not
everything is gray matter our first
analyses really
uh dependent on on free surfer and fsl
for
for their analysis but of course there's
also diffusion tensor imaging data
resting state
functional imaging data and uh the
latest
uh development effort is in a pipeline
for analyzing magnetic resonance
spectroscopy results across
multiple sites and studies
and again remember all of this data is
collected
long before it's analyzed for an enigma
approach these are all data sets
in all of these um studies that are
previously collected so they were
collected
as best fit the needs of the people
running those studies at the time
as best fit the abilities of whatever
scanning centers they were using at the
time so they are highly heterogeneous
data collection methods neuroimaging
parameters etc and so half the challenge
in developing an enigma pipeline is
really identifying
what is it that we can do to address the
heterogeneity across these techniques
the same the different techniques using
these samples that somehow
main maintains the effect sizes and the
sensitivity
across the samples we don't want to just
wipe out any effects that we might be
finding but at the same time we don't
want to introduce
artifact so briefly uh this is an
example from 2013
introducing the enigma dti pipeline
where they had access to
multiple family studies and they could
uh identify
that the header the heritability of
white matter
um was the same when it was run through
the enigma dti pipeline
whether they did a meta-analysis or a
mega analysis they didn't introduce any
artifacts and that the overall pattern
results was very similar across the
different white matter tracks which gave
us
some confidence that this dti pipeline
was what we wanted
and then the schizophrenia groups the
bipolar groups and the major depression
groups have all published
the white matter case control effects
using this pipeline
and in a recent paper that just came out
maybe i think this past month um the
working with a japanese consortium so
the kokoro consortium is an
a japanese version of enigma where they
have their own
multi-site data set aggregation
and analysis approach for meta-analysis
and they
basically used the enigma pipeline and
looked at their schizophrenia samples
and looked at the
um the what the effect sizes that they
were finding and how that correlated
with the effect size that the enigma
schizophrenia
um group had already published and as
you can see there's a whoppingly high
correlation so it's highly reproducible
in these case control
effects across different parts of the
white matter
in international samples bipolar
disorder
also very high correlation not as tight
as in schizophrenia and in major
depression
still a good correlation but um weaker
probably due to the the heterogeneity of
depression i always thought
schizophrenia was a highly heterogeneous
um disorder but it's got nothing on on
major depression which is just
incredibly um uh
different in its different different
presentations
so given that enigma is hit 10 years
there's actually a special issue all
about enigma
looking at sort of a 10-year
retrospective that just came out in
human brain mapping
quite recently i think almost now that
maybe out into
two different um issues and it's
covering um
over 30 papers there's really quite a
lot there you can spend the whole year
just reading your way through
this this issue and in many cases it
really falls under three themes
one is looking at working groups and
what they have done
either some of the newer working groups
such as epilepsy
or um or stroke recovery which is uh
some of the newer working groups
or comparisons across the different
working groups so the adhd and the
autism groups have been working together
more recently and it's a review of what
what they've been doing
and what they've been finding etc there
are a number of methods papers so what
do we know about the dti
pipeline what have we been able to use
it to find
out comparing meta versus mega analysis
so what do we
see when we do a meta-analysis versus
actually pull all the data together into
one location
um reproducibility questions and then
empirical findings either
from using the enigma approach such as
looking at
subcortical shape shape alterations or
trying to apply enigma findings
in the smaller clinical non-enigma data
sets
some of the newer disease groups have
really tackled the heterogeneity of
their
diseases and these more recent papers
are
showing that so for example with
schizophrenia we know that schizophrenia
is a highly heterogeneous disorder
but in our analyses we could basically
say look everybody's either
schizophrenic or they're not they've got
this diagnosis or they don't and we're
just going to roll with that and look at
what we can find just to get the
get the ball rolling um we've looked at
some symptoms severity profiles etc
but in epilepsy and stroke and epilepsy
of course
um the locus of where the epileptic or
the foci of the epileptic seizures could
be in very different places around the
brain
in different data sets um stroke studies
of course stroke can be in very
different parts of the brain
and they really had to tackle the
heterogeneity of their data
and how are they going to put that
together in these large-scale
meta-analyses
the anxiety working group had to deal
with the
organization of anxiety disorders they
didn't just focus
on a particular anxiety disorder so they
really took
to heart that within anxiety you have
general anxiety and then you've got the
social anxiety and phobic anxieties and
other anxieties and they wanted to break
to say
try to tease apart what is specific to
anxiety and what is specific to the
different disorders or what is general
to anxiety and what is specific to the
different anxiety subdivisions if you
will
very interesting reading and approaches
there
one of the translations of the enigma
findings to
the clinic is the regional vulnerability
index that
peter kochenov and his team have
identified
and it really takes advantage of the
fact that all the enigma findings
are downloadable so across
for example the schizophrenia findings
we have for every brain region from the
free circle
free surfer cortical output we know
what the case control effect size is and
what
its confidence range is so we have a
profile if you will of what the
schizophrenic
effects are across the brain and we can
apply this to
any data set um any neuroimaging dataset
that you might have
where if you start with your controls
you can get sort of the mean
for your sample what is the mean
thickness or measurement for example of
of every brain region in this
parcellation
you can then for each subject look at
how they deviate from
your controls so for your your controls
are going to obviously have some
variability
around the mean and your patients if you
have individuals with schizophrenia
um will also deviate from the mean of
the of the healthy controls and so every
subject
now has a sort of vector of z scores
showing whether where they are
deviating from the mean and by how much
and of course you can then
correlate that with the enigma
schizophrenia findings across these same
regions
so that the regional vulnerability index
is the correlation of between their
regional z-scores and the cohen's d
scores
across the region so a higher
correlation means that their pattern of
thickness deviations from the norm is
more similar
to what we've seen in case control
differences in the worldwide sample
which is a lovely idea and what can you
do with it and what
peter's team did was say well we have
you know 120 or 200
patients and a bunch of controls and we
can look within the patients at
those who are earlier in their disorder
or intermediate their disorder or those
who've had the disorder for
for many decades and look at their
subcortical measures their cortical
measures their white matter and they
actually came up with a way to do a
regional
vulnerability index that combined all of
these measures
and they could show that they're
basically their controls have no
regional
regional vulnerability patients do have
a regional vulnerability across all
modalities so they correlate with what's
been seen
in these worldwide samples
and in subcortically and in white matter
you can actually
see effects across the duration of
illness
so that patients who are sort of early
in their diagnostic stage
look you know a little bit more like
healthy controls than that do the folks
who are more chronic in all cases
and the substance abuse disorders
working group also looked at a very
similar kind of approach saying we have
our own patterns
of findings in substance use how does
that compare to the psychiatric
disorders where do we see a similar
pattern where do we not
um so enigma of course people always ask
how do i join up how do i get involved
if you have
imaging data that is relevant to any of
the questions
um that any of the working groups are
are looking at whether it's disorder
related or methodology related etc um
just
you can you can talk to the chair of the
of the working group
and and get involved usually people are
affiliated with some data set either
directly or indirectly
um if you have a method that you're
interested in trying out generally
speaking
many of the working groups are very open
to that we've certainly seen folks from
you know bipolar or ptsd
working groups come over to
schizophrenia and say hey we're finding
this really interesting thing
in these other groups can we try it and
schizophrenia even though they
themselves don't have schizophrenia data
and sometimes if you have an interesting
question
you can certainly make a connection
within the relevant um enigma working
group
i have had people come to me and say oh
can i get access to the enigma data
because i want to do this the
other thing i have a new approach and
usually the response is look
make a connection with someone who has
the relevant data
show us how it's being done on that
particular data set
and then you'll you'll get the working
group leaders and the
data set liaison sort of going sure i'm
happy to give it a shot on
on my data but you want to sort of you
don't want to just walk up and say i
can't hand you the data
for enigma because everybody controls
their own
within the large-scale enigma analysis
of course we've identified
privacy issues one of the reasons why
enigma exists is so we don't have to
actually give away
our data and within that special issue
vince calhoun has written a paper about
the software he's been developing
specifically to address the issues
of privacy within the data sharing
drive within the neuroimaging community
so vince calhoun who's now
at georgia state has been developing the
collaborative informatics and
neuroimaging suite toolkit
for anonymous computation or coin stack
and it is exactly what it sounds like it
is a collaborative
informatics and no imaging suite so it's
a data management data
processing suite of tools
that is now available for anonymous
collaborative computation so the idea is
very much like the enigma model someone
can
install the coinstack software link it
up to the data
that they have available and collaborate
with other people around the world who
want to do these
same kinds of analyses on similar kind
of data without having to actually
upload your data
or send it to everybody you want to
collaborate with etc
it allows obviously researchers from
around the world to collaborate
with the automated approach it can now
include decentralized learning
algorithms advanced statistical and
machine learning analyses
so that you don't you can do iterative
algorithms iterative computations which
previously
had required that all the data be in one
place so that you can iterate over it
because certainly the human driven
approach that we've used in
enigma largely is not conducive to to
shipping information back and optimizing
parameters et cetera et cetera you can
you only get one shot
but with these automated approaches you
can have the you can now
decentralize your iterative algorithms
and
um and apply them without transmitting
individual level data
and you can incorporate differentially
private
computations in the software level so
that you
can protect against malicious attacks
that might be trying to reconstruct your
data
and get at the privacy information that
you're trying to hide so we have we can
actually work
in privacy protection at that level
and currently it is of course open
source free software um
easily extensible it's based in docker
it'll run computations
in r python matlab et cetera and it runs
on windows mac and linux
obviously there's still a lot to do with
it but basically the lead site
defines the local analysis that will be
run locally and the global analysis that
would be run at the lead site when it
gets all the results back
in the kind of automation of the enigma
approach
the participating sites basically can
see exactly how their data is being used
they're not giving up control
of their data in any way they agree to
allow their data to be used they then
join the consortium get the analyses
that are supposed to be done
and when everything's ready the lead
site actually
fires off the analysis which is then run
automatically at every
site no post docs required and and
returns the intermediate data to the
lead
site we have implemented of course
regression
as well as these d centralized
more interesting kinds of algorithms
perhaps including
deep learning and independent components
analysis and support vector machines etc
and of course
we've bundled up the r scripts to try to
do replications of the enigma analyses
and so uh vince and theo van erp and i
have sort of put together the enigma
schizophrenia
and coinstack uh efforts and were
recently uh funded or actually refunded
last year
to ask questions about
enigma schizophrenia or really about
schizophrenic
brain measures and negative symptoms so
within schizophrenia
we were very interested in negative
symptoms
we already had papers out looking at
across the enigma schizophrenia working
group looking at negative symptoms and
cortical thickness
and had total negative symptoms severity
was related to various areas in the
inferior frontal cortex
but that's really not the final word we
know that
structure and white matter and function
probably all play a role
in identifying what's going on with
negative symptoms
and with the coin stack interactions and
the coin stack
infrastructure we could look at each one
of these
individually against the negative
symptom measures we could look at
multivariate combinations of these
different measures
and we can of course lead to machine
learning approaches to try to predict
from combinations of these features what
the negative symptoms are that
any given patient is suffering from and
then we could try to generalize that
by interacting with the enigma bipolar
disorder group getting them to do the
same sorts of analyses
and then generalize that to major
depression to see whether the negative
symptoms the
anhedonia apathy etc um play a role in
what we see in major depression or
really or whether
um the psychosis disorders are very
different
so within schizophrenia there are
actually um
very different uh negative symptom
profiles
across men and women um generally
speaking
women seem to be more affected women
with schizophrenia should be more
affected by
mood and and depressive symptoms and the
affect
um the affective symptoms whereas men
generally tend to have more severe
negative symptoms apathy and hedonia
withdrawal of all sorts but it's not
specific
to mood disorders and so we use
this as an initial um examination within
the coin stack framework
to say can we just look at sex
differences
in our negative symptoms measurements
across a number of different sites
so we had as a first test we had seven
different sites that had collected as
you can see very small samples
you know 30 28 30 subjects
each with a breakdown of men and women
um uh participants same general age
duration of illness
varying from very early on in their
duration of a very short duration of
illness to very long duration of illness
at every site
the sands is the scales for the
assessment of negative symptoms and
again
within each site there's really quite a
range from
individuals with really no negative
symptoms where most of their symptoms
might have been
more of the positive symptoms like
hallucinations but they didn't have a
lot of the negative symptoms of
withdrawal and apathy and
blunted affect etc and then there are
other people within each site who had
quite severe negative symptoms
and so we could actually run across we
could use the coinstack in
coinstack infrastructure to run a
factor analysis on the different
negative symptoms and look at the sex
differences
across the negative symptom factors
and then we could look at the
meta-analysis and we said we basically
what would have taken um a few months of
rolling things out to individual sites
we could do over the course of an
hour by just setting it up and and
letting it run automatically
um we did a hierarchical factor analysis
for those of you who are
interested in sort of the nitty-gritty
of our negative symptoms there's a two
factor uh solution which is um
motivation
and expressiveness and then there's a
five-factor solution that's really
embedded
in the two-factor solution and what we
were seeing was generally speaking
um men had more severe negative symptoms
relative to women and that this was
really only significant
in the expressive um factor and then
factors four and five which dealt with
which really contributed to the
expressive factor show the same pattern
so we're
this is very nice and that we're
replicating what's been seen in the
literature
and particularly in large scale analyses
where they aggregated all the data and
ran it all together we could actually
um run this in an automated system and
get what we expect to see
and then we can step forward and say
okay we did that we've got our coin
stack system working let's look at brain
volumes because what do we see
with our negative symptoms and and brain
measurements and again
using um the coin stack infrastructure
and
some of the sites couldn't do that so
they would have to run it themselves and
we'd put it all together but
um using the coin stack infrastructure
we could look at um
avolition and anedonia which are two of
the
negative symptoms of schizophrenia that
are considered to be related to sort of
positive
valence um sort of positive emotions
sort of a lack of positive emotions
abolition and anedonia
and then deficits in social processing
which is asociality or blunted
withdrawal from social interactions
blunted affect and
um and no no talking basically logia
and we could again use these analyses to
do exactly the same
sorts of analyses i was actually
expecting to see
a lot of the inferior frontal regions
being related to
negative symptoms as we see here because
that is what we had seen in previous
analyses
when we looked at just total symptom
severity as opposed to breaking it down
and seeing which negative symptoms were
related to the brain
regions because it turns out the
positive valence seems to be related to
on the areas that we were seeing before
but the social processing is a very
different um
pattern and it's really fantastic to be
able to to look at this
we're still wrapping this up this is
sort of initial
uh primary results we have a few more
sites that are coming in
for analysis and of course our next
developments are just to say
we know that structure is just the
beginning of the question we're working
on the dti analysis similarly and
resting
state and then put it all together
because the test will be can we actually
use these brain measures to really
predict the different negative symptom
profiles that we have across different
individuals
in these data sets
so in summary we've got a few minutes
here
so large scale data management and
particularly management of
access to the data for data sharing
as well as methods for large-scale data
analysis and meta-analysis are really
becoming
duragar if you will in our imaging
certainly more much more common
the analyses are becoming more powerful
and more nuanced over time the
heterogeneity of the disorders
can really be attacked with these kinds
of large scale approaches
combinations of meta and mega analysis
can be very
informative again meta-analysis is where
you leave the data in one place mega
analyses
is usually where you have to combine the
data there are approaches for performing
what is effectively a mega analysis in a
decentralized
environment so that's very promising
because it is really the best of both
worlds structural functional and dti
analysis pipelines are currently
available with others uh
coming um and novel approaches of course
to these decentralized analyses are
becoming available and very
powerful for being able to really
access federated or decentralized data
to be able to get the power of these
large-scale data sets without pulling it
all together and having to invest
in massive data repositories
uh the initial results from enigma all
of their working groups are
are public and can be reused the initial
code from
coinstack is available on our github
site and it's in
these slides as well this allows for
comparisons across
disorders and diagnostic boundaries and
allows for
prediction and classic classification
techniques without
data sharing when you put enigma
data access and and coin stack
techniques
together so that's hopefully uh the
beginnings of the future
for these kinds of analyses so in
conclusion
i do want to again address remind
everybody the key issues of the power
that comes from these kinds
of questions the computational
efficiency
that comes from these kinds of
approaches and shared
data access shared data considerations
it really pushes open science and
reproducibility
forward because these meta-analyses in
particular with the forest plots
really highlight the variability across
different data sets and what you might
expect to see if you run it yourself
on your own data set but of course is
pushing team science
forward and of course advancing science
by interacting together to try to answer
the same question
once and for all as opposed to having to
do it uh multiple times and argue about
it
in in the literature per se
so we can of course download github so i
wanted to make sure everybody
has access to that information we're
very happy to hear from you if you
download it and try to run it or want to
get involved
and i did want to acknowledge both the
nsf and the nih support that has gone
into all of these efforts i didn't
encore
include all of the enigma enigma grants
but certainly the ones that have been
interacted with coinstack this is uh
vince's teams many of whom are working
on developing these algorithms and
and software as well as other questions
this is my lab
at georgia state many of whom are
interacting with
uh the enigma approaches and this is
a group of the enigma a subset if you
will of the enigma working group
leaders getting together for their
annual meeting
before the organization for human brain
mapping uh meeting in 2019
back when we could actually all get
together and and stand together
and hopefully we'll be able to do that
again in the future so thank you very
much
dr turner thank you so much for that
great overview of enigma and coinstack
and it's uh
several examples of their application um
that have led to some pretty prominent
um peer-reviewed
literature uh that's fantastic and thank
you so much for sharing that
um i want to invite our
biomedical data science innovation lab
attendees
to submit questions via their chat
feature in zoom
and while those are accumulating jess
i'd like to ask you a couple of things
while we wait um so it looks like enigma
has solved many of these sociological
issues that are involved in data sharing
and
certainly promotes uh open science and
collaboration
i'm curious if you've also solved the
cat hurting problem of getting all those
people to do things in a timely fashion
and answer emails and uh what some of
the what's some of the
the coordination that has to go into
having um some of these
uh multi-site multi-country multi-time
zone
collaborations well you know there's
there's an entire book that could
probably be written
about lessons learned from trying to run
these large-scale
techniques um and i'm sure anybody who's
done it whether it's in neuroimaging or
geoscience or whatever would have would
have similar approaches
um but no we have not solved the cat
hurting problem
and in many cases and i i can speak as
somebody who's been um
running the working group for probably
longer than i should uh in many cases uh
the
the energy of the of the people who have
joined more recently
um is embarrassing to those of us who've
been around for a while and are starting
to slow down
and not be able to uh focus on these
these
uh analyses quite as much as we should
like to um
so no i think a lot of it has to do with
having um well there's a number of
things one is
we we found that co-chairing working
groups is really important no one person
can do it by themselves and having two
people sort of
you know keeps it it's it is a bit of
cat hurting but at the same time it's a
bit like having cats that play together
you know they're much more likely to to
stay healthy if they're not doing it on
their own and feeling like it's all
on their own so i strongly recommend um
anybody who's starting up a group like
this to have a team
going into it as as leaders and then um
there have been a number of graduate
students and postdocs who have made
enigma projects their their dissertation
um and i think to a person they have all
said that was
probably slowing things down
tremendously
not from the point of view of enigma
enigma was quite happy to see you know
the larger groups
we're very happy to see um somebody
dedicated to these projects and actually
getting papers out and the papers have
been very successful
but each individual sort of said i
probably ended up taking a year or two
longer with my dissertation than i would
have if i had focused on something a
little bit smaller
and they basically recommend that you
you do this as a post-doc but not
necessarily as a graduate student
yeah i was going to ask about the use of
enigma as a
device for undergraduate graduate or you
know postdoctoral education
and i was curious uh if you know about
examples of that sounds like there's
some graduate students who do this is
this something that you have
guys have considered kind of broadening
to cover more of the spectrum
educational spectrum um no because it's
hard enough to keep it moving much less
turn it into anything else but no i
think it's
really a brilliant idea i certainly have
brought people in in my
lab as as graduate students a number of
them are
working on you know learning r and
trying to turn these analyses
into r and what does it take to actually
um work with these kinds of
international
consortia and i know other groups have
written um
graduate
basically funding grants to try to fund
graduate students to work on it we don't
have a coordinated r25 for example like
you have or anything like that but i
think that's
probably something we should we should
consider oh fantastic
um one of the questions that is is
coming in is
about the kind of geographic diversity
and ethnic diversity that you have in
enigma and that
seems it's a lot of the data are coming
from uh european
yes and people of european ancestry
and whether or not there's any interest
in including other populations are
performing kind of trans
ethnic meta yes yes absolutely
absolutely if you look at our maps i
mean every time we got
you know we got researchers on new
continents or new countries
uh there was always a celebration um
and it's been it's been very interesting
trying to work with people from
around the world i think obviously from
the point of view of the genetics
europe and the us sort of had a running
start
on that um china japan
and many of the asian countries
certainly have
whopping um groups doing those analyses
um and they are much more open to doing
meta analyses than to actually sharing
the
data um and i think that has certainly
helped out a lot and they were
absolutely um included in some of the
more recent ones the first
the first paper was largely caucasian um
but certainly as the genetic
abilities for cross um cross racial
cross
ethnic um comparisons have gotten better
um that's sort of grown up
hand-in-hand with worldwide um
enigmagenetics analyses
that's nice absolutely i mean africa
unfortunately many of the countries in
africa are still
not at that point um but we're looking
forward to the day when when we'll have
dots all over that part of the world as
well
that'd be fantastic now you mentioned um
there was a lot of
the work that you described was looking
at the data from a meta-analytic
point of view and i mean that's part of
the way enigma is
structured is to look for kind of
meta-analytic
findings but you also mentioned that
there are some mega
analytic tools and machinery that exists
and
obviously meta-analysis is going to be
an analysis of those analyses but
getting all the raw data together is
kind of a different scale
of analysis and it puts more of the onus
on getting all that data into either
one space or at least fewer spaces in
order to kind of do it efficiently
what are some of the things which are
happening that uh support mega analysis
well
that's a that's a great a great question
and it's it over the last 10 years
there's been sort of ups and downs if
you will um because certainly as
as you noted the meta analytic approach
was really what
let enigma get rolling because people
said oh oh i can i can do this i don't
have to give away my data
um and then there was a sort of pushback
as some of the first papers came out and
of course reviewers you know reviewer
two
always wants another analysis um and
that slows down
analog it slows down paper responses
when you have to now
distribute your analyses to you know 30
places and and get the results back and
and integrate it and revise the paper
accordingly
um and so a number of the working groups
said can we start
sharing data because literally for the
purposes of writing the papers
you know to say when an analysis comes
back we need to be able to have access
to the data very quickly to be able to
run these analyses
and what they were finding is that many
of the groups were
in the early days so we're talking you
know 2012 2013-14
uh many of the groups were willing to
share the free surfer output so they
could share
for example the um subject level level
volumes or measurements but not the raw
images so when they when they were doing
mega analyses they could get mega
analyses at the level at that level so
at the level of the spreadsheet at the
level
of the um the regional volumes
or the tractography volumes etc um they
could do
that but they couldn't necessarily share
the the raw images
um with the invocation of the gdpr
that's become more difficult sure so
they were just getting that
up and rolling and becoming you know
sort of the standard way of figuring
that out and then then
even the european countries said no
sorry we really have to
have to you know pull back on that um so
in many cases those of us who sort of
stuck with the meta-analytic approach or
focusing on
coinstack and these automated approaches
um
i have have sort of had to step in to
say you know there's
there's still things we can do the world
isn't over just because you can't share
your raw data
we can put in this software layer that
allows access to the data allows access
to these kinds of mega analyses we
wanted to do
without having to um well while
protecting everybody's privacy and
confidentiality
what are some of the issues with the
genetics
data um i guess this is probably all
singular
yeah single nucleotide polymorphism data
yeah um
and you know presumably some of the data
is
you know older using different chip
technology and
um there's some there's some
heterogeneity there and of course
increasingly
there's interest in getting you know
full genome sequencing
how is tell us a little bit more about
that what are some of the issues there
and how do you expect things to change
as people are starting to you know get
gigabytes worth of genome data
well let's that is um an area of active
development
okay for just the reasons that you've
highlighted because we're now
looking at you know genome-wide
association data was coming out in 2005
2006
um and it's now 2020.
and so as you yeah this date there is
incredibly heterogeneous
um genetic data and a great deal one of
the reasons the first paper took
three years to write was to figure out
how to
um deal with that and how to how to um
do quality assurance on it when you you
know you hand off code
and everybody goes oh yeah yeah we're
using the right build and oh yeah yeah
we're doing this and we're doing that
how do you actually make sure that they
that it's been done
in with some sort of objective
measurement on the data
how do you check for um making sure that
they don't have relatives in their
sample or if they do
you know that those have been taken into
account properly so there's a huge
amount of effort
put into that and that's just as you
pointed out for the single nucleotide
polymorphism data
and it just expands as you move into the
newer
techniques of methylation measurements
and
other kinds of and whole genome
sequencing etc so that is an area where
that's one of the reasons that genomics
working group is huge and they're
collaborating with international
genetics groups as well
um to try to develop methods that are
robust
to you know having an undergrad
implement the scripts on your data set
um you want you know who doesn't have a
dissertation in genetics behind them but
you can still make
robust techniques that they can use and
it looks like there's also some working
groups on epigenetics
and it looked like um there might be
some gene expression
activities going on as well so it's not
just the
um you know the variation in atc's and
g's but their
uh expression and any epigenetic factors
is that right
absolutely absolutely
requires a huge amount of of you know
conversation and trial and error to get
it right
uh yeah absolutely i mean for those of
us who are just still kind of coming to
grips with
you know genetics uh having to remember
our biochemistry it's just that
whole that whole side of things just
keeps marching away from me personally
and i
it's a continual unbelievable i love my
collaborations with the folks who really
can focus on the genetics because they
don't really care about the brain and
how we measure the brain
but they can tell me everything about
the latest and greatest understanding of
how
the structure of the chromosome and the
way it's bent affects the the expression
of the genes so you really it's not just
knowing the gene and how it correlates
you have to know where it is and
you know what else is going on
absolutely remarkable and in the second
i think i understand it and
try to implement anything oh no that's
that's not how we do it you haven't
factored in
the you know the the the gc bias you
know i got to take that into account oh
okay
great i didn't know about that um
one of our attendees is asking what
specific areas
are longitudinal studies um which are
being undertaken within
enigma and this particular person is
particularly interested in uh sex
difference
uh research across the life span into
things like dementia risk is there
things
are related to this um from a
longitudinal point yes
yes yes yes um uh paul thompson works
closely with uh
nada jahanshan jahanshad also at usc and
neda is running a
grant a very small grant on enigma sex
differences
where what she is doing is not actually
running any analyses
but every group that does an analysis we
almost always include
sex as a covariate but it's a covariate
of no interest
we usually just want to account for it
but we don't really care about it
and what she's doing is saying please
send me your results anytime you include
sex differences in your model send me
the results so we can look at the
effects
of sex differences and really try to put
that all together in like this massive
dashboard where you can integrate
where do you see sex differences whether
it's in case control effects or
in changes over time because we do have
longitudinal analyses going on
or in symptom severity or what have you
no i'm happy to put anybody in touch
with uh with nada
if you're interested in working on
something like that that's great
um so you mentioned people who are
interested in connecting with parts of
the enigma consortium can reach out to
the
um to the uh kind of sub-section leaders
if you will um what would uh somebody
need to do to say right to you
what would you need to see in order to
say okay these guys might be uh
worth taking the risk on to to partner
with
we have a number of people who i'm sure
going to be very interested in sure
absolutely
one of the best places to start is to go
to the enigma website
um and i'm pretty sure i included that
early on in one of the slides and i can
happily send it to you
um jack to forward on if anyone wants to
know if you can't find it with google
um but there's if you go to the go to
the website we list who all the chairs
are in the various working groups
paul thompson has an absolutely
phenomenal project manager
who is sort of a central uh emailing hub
and many many many people will email um
paul and sophia tomopolis who is the
project manager
um and and say i'm interested in joining
and she usually
figures out where they need to go and
who they need to talk to
um so i get an email from her probably
once every you know every few months
with somebody saying oh here's this
group in israel here's this group in
buenos aires or something
and then we reach out to them and say
hey you know what what are you doing
what would you why do you want to be
involved what are you what are you
looking at
and um and just double checking that
they can really be a participant
because um ideally what i was i was
pointing out if somebody comes in and
says oh you know i basically want to
build my career on the backs of all the
data that you have collected
um we still go wait a minute hold up
hold up
um but if somebody comes in and goes hey
i've got you know 15 schizophrenics and
15 controls i can't do anything with it
but i'm really interested in this
question and here's what i'm doing
and can i maybe roll these methods out
to some of these other samples
um we're happy to chat with them
absolutely happy to chat with them
that's fantastic now uh one final
question is that
there are a lot of different working
groups which are very disease or
disorder specific
are there any sort of things which are
trying to look across the spectrum of
things to kind of uh identify
commonalities which might exist between
i think you had mentioned an example
like autism and adhd but
you know might you have something
between you know in other
mental illnesses or other neurological
conditions so look for some of these
kind of more
um i'm thinking of things like the the
nimh's
efforts to kind of re-define how we
think of mental
illness um to kind of look at the the
actual
um biomarker patterns and then ask
whether or not those map
onto what we think of as schizophrenia
for example
are there activities going on like that
yeah absolutely and enigma is very open
to supporting that kind of
um of activity i mean the enigma
coinstack grant
is exactly taking advantage of nih's
desire to see cross-diagnostic questions
so we can start we start by asking
questions within schizophrenia and then
seeing it generalizes
um to bipolar disorder and major
depression that's the kind of thing that
people want to see
there is a cross disorder working group
within bipolar disorder schizophrenia
major depression
and i think attention deficit disorder
but it may just be those first three
where we're really trying to compare
results across groups and say what what
is it that we're really seeing that is
similar that is different
because there are even though there are
similarities there are of course disease
specific effects such
as um the the propensity within men and
women so we do see sex differences
um and just in in how many
individuals you get uh with
schizophrenia versus bipolar there are
obviously differences in medication
there are differences in the trajectory
of the disorder but what what does that
do to the brain and how do we tease that
apart
what good does that tell us absolutely
there are folks doing that um and then a
number of those
papers um that i talked about in the bm
or in the hbm special issue are focusing
on cross disorder groups
much of that is organic so we don't have
a cross disorder
working group per se we sort of have a
an ad hoc
you know effort between this group and
that group are these three groups or
those four groups based on common
interests
that's really interesting it would be uh
really kind of interesting to see
kind of a enigma
perhaps a big mega meta analysis
done using enigma uh to look for brain
commonalities and things which might be
um uh uh just kind of connect what we
think of as distinct disorders
that are really kind of kind of
different flavors of the same disorder
or alternatively look for things where
we think we understand
that there are they're they're called
one thing
but they're actually multiple different
sub disorders yeah
we really want to dig into that with
these disorders that we know are just
not uniform in any way which is almost
all of them
yeah exactly uniform well i i
i think i've run out of questions and it
looks like our participants have
as well so i want to thank you uh dr
turner for for sharing with us
uh your work and the work of this
impressive international team on enigma
and your work going on at uh
georgia state um to in uh coinstack and
all of the activities going on there
that is very exciting what a fantastic
resource that has been constructed i
can't believe it's been 10 years
that enigma has been around i remember
when it was a twinkle
in paul thompson's eye
so it's fantastic to see a success story
from someone like him and yourself and
all of your collaborators
uh people i really respect and admire so
um thank you very much for sharing that
with us i want to thank all of our
participants for for joining in if you
are interested in
anything enigma uh you know where to go
um and as coinstack as well uh everyone
have a very good
weekend uh thank you for joining us and
uh look forward to uh
seeing you next week thank you thanks so
much